Crash test executing in three, two, one...
So this is our crash test lab.
The test vehicle starts at the end of the
track about 340 feet away.
We attach the vehicle to the propulsion system,
to the steel cable here.
The two Model S Performance drive units pull the test
vehicle all the way down the track until it's
about three feet away from the wall.
Well in advance of us ever producing a physical
prototype
we're running thousands of crash simulations.
At the design level we'll produce 3D models
of the parts and we'll simulate those using
very complex and sophisticated mathematical
models that represent the physics of a crash.
One unique passive safety feature in the Model
3 is its specially designed front passenger
airbag, which helps protect the occupant in
oblique crashes where they might come into
contact with the interior.
Safety is a top priority so I think that's
really encouraging to see feedback from people
that have got into serious crashes and they
give you that feedback that you've saved their
lives and the lives of their loved ones.
It's a really great feeling and shows that
the work that we're doing is worthwhile.